are you looking to upgrade your
microscope well microcosmos do store is
the place for you we've got a selection
of plan a chromatic objectives ranging
from 4X all the way up to 100x and these
objectives don't just work on the
microcosmos microscope they will work on
other dinin standard compound
microscopes because of the way lenses
are made Regular achromatic objectives
display a curved image which results in
the edges of the field being slightly
distorted and out of focus but these
plan objectives produce a flatter image
across the entire field of view
resulting in an overall Sharper Image
which is great if like us you enjoy
capturing pictures and videos of your
samples so go to micro cosmos. store if
you want to upgrade your objectives or
pick up any other microcosmos
merchandise in
1864 Lou pastor stood up in front of a
crowd at the sarbon scientific Suare to
deliver an address and he started by
saying a number of imposing problems now
have our best Minds
inth those imposing questions covered
everything from the history of humankind
to the concept of species but pastur
promised the crowd he would not be
answering any of those questions what
Pastor wanted to address was a question
much more fundamental can life be
created
[Music]
spontaneously the concept Pastor wanted
to discuss was called spontaneous
generation which posited that perhaps
living things could just like appear
from some other kind of matter though
there were various ideas about how
exactly that could work it was an old
Theory and it took several centuries
worth of experiments to prove that it
was wrong unfortunately we of course do
not have footage of these experiments
but a year and a half ago our master of
microscopes James was inspired by the
idea of spontaneous generation and set
up his own experiment he cut a plastic
bottle in half and flipped the top half
so he could place it in the bottom half
like a funnel and keep it from spilling
then he placed his Contraption outside
to see what would show up the plan was
to return a few weeks later but he
forgot and in his defense he had a lot
of other microbes to watch when James
eventually remembered and went to check
it out he found a brownish residue and a
bunch of dead bugs on the bottom of the
bottle and of course because he is James
the first thing he did was put putot it
under the microscope so we could see the
array of microscopic creatures dwelling
within the question that spontanous
generation sought to answer is how those
creatures got into that bottle and there
were several ideas around how life could
spontaneously generate one Theory called
a biogenesis proposed that life could
arise from non-living matter like
scallops forming from the sand they are
found in another theory was called
heterogenesis and it suggested that life
could form from another species that was
living or had once been living like
insects that show up out of nowhere on
decaying flesh Aristotle describes both
of these theories of spontaneous
generation in his treaties the history
of animals but he was not the first or
only person to believe in spontaneous
generation in pastor's speech he
described an old recipe to make
mice simply add a dirty shirt to a
vessel filled with wheat grains and then
wait 21 days at the end of the waiting
period you will find the wheat
transformed into
mice it's easy enough to laugh at these
ideas now like we know how cells work
and that they exist and how they
reproduce and pass along a life encoded
in DNA that in turn begets more life and
as we watch the creatures from James's
bottle floating across our
we know enough about microbes to know
how they got there many of them were in
the air making up an invisible universe
that found its way into the bottle
through rain or wind or some other
element but if you lived in a world
where you did not know that microbes can
travel through the air James's
experiment would be much harder to
interpret are there really unseen
creatures traveling an imperceptible
path all around us in the air and the
rain or are they the product of a
chemical reaction that we just haven't
found the formula to yet on its own this
bottle can't find the explanation in
fact no single experiment could resolve
the spontaneous generation debate every
experiment performed was in conversation
with the experiments and ideas that came
before it and each experiment set the
scene for the work that followed for
example in the middle of the 17th
century an Italian scientist named
Franchesco ready put meat in sealed jars
to demonstrate that maggots did not
spontaneously generate from decaying
flesh but while his experiment helped
people understand that maggots come from
very small eggs other advances
complicated matters including our
favorite invention the
[Music]
microscope in pastor's words but at the
end of the 17th century a tremendous
discovery that of the microscope
revealed an entire new world to man man
the world of the infinitesimally small
so while it had most assuredly been
vanquished as far as the higher
creatures were concerned the doctrine of
spontaneous generation now reappeared
audaciously declaring here is my
Province microbes are small and often
associated with decaying matter so they
provided a new vessel for the ideas of
spontaneous generation and heterogenesis
in the middle of of the 18th century one
English botanist named John NM set out
to investigate the spontaneous
generation of microbes by boiling broth
the aim was to kill whatever was living
in there so that after the broth cooled
down and was then sealed he could
compare it to another flask of broth
that had not been heated when NM found
that both the unheated and heated broths
turned cloudy he concluded that microbes
must have spontaneously generated in
those FL asks how else could they get
there well we know the answer and we are
seeing it in action now there are
microbes in the air that found their way
into the experiment but remember we did
not know this at the time but lazaros
banani an Italian biologist had an
inkling that this could be the case and
that perhaps there were microbes in the
air contaminated nm's flasks so
spalanzani repeated the experiment but
in a way he could seal the flask before
boiling it and under spallanzani's
conditions no microbes appeared this
seems like a blow for spontaneous
generation but as scientists better
understood the importance of oxygen to
cellular respiration some began to
wonder if spalanzani was wrong what if
microbes could spontaneously generate
just not in the air deprived environment
he had
[Music]
created
scientists went back and forth over
whether this was the case engaging in a
dialogue told through different
experimental setups but by the time
Pastor took the stage none of the
experiments before him on either side
could fully seal the holes in their
argument Pastor disagreed with the
theory of spontaneous generation and he
decided to test his ideas by building on
the same premise that many of his
predecessors had used in their
experiments kill off all the organisms
in a flask and watched to see if
Anything Grows but he needed to prevent
contamination from any organisms
potentially flying through the air while
also ensuring that there was air present
to nourish organisms if they did manage
to spontaneously generate in the broth
this is like kind of a complicated and
contradictory set of parameters for an
experiment and Pastor found an elegant
solution he bent the neck of a flask
into an S creating a swan-like shape
after pastur boiled the nutrient broth
in the flask and killed the organisms
within it the s-shaped neck allowed air
to flow through but Pastor thought the
shape would make it hard for particles
traveling in the air to get into the
broth trapping microbes before they
could get into the flask and so it was
not a surprise to him that the broth
remained clear uncontaminated by
microbes pasture however was not done he
went wanted to see if the microbes he
expected to be trapped in the neck of
the flask were really there so he tipped
the flask to the side and allowed the
broth to reach into the S shape when he
did that the broth eventually became
cloudy he had shown that his broth did
not fill with microbes
spontaneously pestor gets much of the
credit for disproving spontaneous
generation maybe in part because it fed
into his understanding of fermentation
and The Germ theory of disease
and when we lay out the story like this
the path to his Discovery seems kind of
linear one experiment beets another
which beets another and so on flask
after flask made murky with microbes
like the bottle James set up in his
backyard but there are so many figures
missing from our telling of this story
like John Tindle the Irish physicist who
investigated invalidated pastor's Theory
or pastor's opposition like the
pathologist Henry Charlton Bastion and
there are so many more characters and
conversations of varied forms and tones
that shaped the way this science was
done and the conclusions that were drawn
because ultimately the uncovering of
knowledge is a very human Affair a
search for Beginnings buried in a hidden
world a treasure hunt with many
Treasures but no end in
sight thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the Unseen
World that surrounds us these folks here
are our patreon patrons if you put them
in a flask and boil it I would be so mad
at you how would we make this show
without them it's not like they
spontaneously generate they are
individual people making individual
decisions because they want things like
this to exist on the internet thank you
so much to all of them and if you would
like to see your name here you can go to
patreon.com journeyto micro where you
can also find out about some of the cool
perks you can get if you want to see
more from our master of microscopes
James Weiss you can check out jam and
germs on Instagram and if you want to
see more from us there's always a
subscribe button somewhere
[Music]
nearby